ربما مفتاح النجاح والابداع في عملك يكمن
في شيء لم تكن تتوقعه القيلوله خذ قيلوله
في عملك حتى ولو لعشر دقائق فقط يعادل
بالتاكيد دراسه امريكيه من جامعه ام اي تي
اتوصلت الى ان النوم لفتره وجيزه بالعمل
يمكن ان يخلق طاقه ابداعيه من خلال مساعده
الدماغ على ربط الافكار المختلفه من
الذاكره الاشخاص الذين اجريت عليهم تجربه
القيلوله اصبحوا اكثر ابداعا بنسبه
43% مقارنه بغيرهم ممن لم يحصلوا عليها
التجارب اثبتت اصابه الموظف لتشتت
ذهني في حال عدم حصوله على قيلوله ما يؤدي
حتما الى عدم القدره على انجاز المهام
[موسيقى]
الله على القيلوله عادل اعترف اعتراف عن
جد عمرك اخدت قيلوله في العمل قيلوله بس
لما انا انسان صباحي
بشري نهاري فبالليل لما اداوم شفت بالليل
مره هي غفوه ما بين الله
وعلى على قصه كانت طالعه
30 ثانيه
لا دقيقه
يعني اخذ قيلوله ساعه يعني اذا كان
في مجال طيب احنا
سالنا الناس مشاهدينا في مصر لو اتيحت لك
فرصه تاخذ قيلوله في عملك هل تستفيد من
الفرصه ولماذا تعسيله مش قيلوله تعسيله
مصر
[موسيقى]
يا اما بغسل وجهي يا اما بشرب فنجان قهوه
لا طبعا يا فندم مش هنام لان الشغل تمام
العمل ده عباده فلازم نعمل تقدير للوقت
بتاعنا تمام واكيد يعني في فترات
فترات ننام فيها برضو بعد ما نخلص الشغل
بتاعنا بتمشي يعني ده اول يوم صعب وتقيل
غير كده الطبيعي بنكمل اليوم زي ما هو من
غير ما نرايق يعني حصلت بس يعني لو في تعب
تعب قبليها يعني ضغط فتره كبيره وكده ممكن
ارتاح شويه لازم نتفق القيلوله دي يعني
مسموح بها ولا لا هل دي من من قواعد
العمل ومسموح يعني مثلا يقال ان في
اليابان
يقولوا لهم يوميا من الساعه كذا لكذا
وانتم في المكتب بتاعكم ممكن تاخدوا
قيلوله دايما باخذها في الشغل انا معظم
وقتي شغلي بره يعني 24 ساعه يعني لو حد
كلمني او حاجه وكنت شغال برده هرجع للشغل
تاني احنا
هاخذها
اه مش هسترجع يعني هاخذها
وهجرب حظي
ولو ظروفي مع الوقت الوقت اللي انا باخد
عليه فلوس ده في اي حاجه تانيه غير
الوظيفه اللي معديها فده مش هيبقى يعني من
حد دينيه حرام وفي نفس الوقت كمان مدمرين
يعني الانسانيه برده مش كويسه
[موسيقى]
هنا ينضم الينا الدكتور توفيق السعدي
اختصاصيه علم الاعصاب يا هلا دكتور حياك
الله صباحك خير صباح الخير حياك الله
دكتور هذه القيلوله او خلينا نقول يعني
العشرين دقيقه او اكثر ما اختلفوا الناس
كم مدتها وش اللي قاعد تسويه بالجسم هلا
العلاقه بين النوم والدماغ علاقه معروفه
من زمان معروف النوم الصحي بعدد ساعات نوم
كافيه تؤثر ايجابا على عمل الدماغ تؤثر
ايجابا على المزاجيه على الحاله النفسيه
وعلى امراض كتير الامراض القلب وغيرها بس
بشرط انه يكون ساعات نوم كافيه بمعنى اخر
العلاقه بين النوم والدماغ علاقه بتاخد
اقل من اربع ساعات ونص نوم تؤثر سلبا على
عمل الدماغ اذا بتزيد ساعات النوم عن عشر
ساعات كمان
له مشاكل
قيلوله خلال النهار هل
احنا محتاجين محتاجينهم ولا حتى لو نمنا 8
ساعات في الليل ايضا بحاجه لقيلوله خلال
النهار هلا القيلوله او النوم هو حاجه
طبيعيه لانه هذا بيعيد نشاط دماغ سواء
اخذنا عدد ساعات كافيه من النوم ليلا او
ما اخذنا ساعاتنا كافيه اذا اخذنا
القيلوله البسيطه الصغيره القصيره بتاثر
ايجابا لانه بتنشط الدماغ بتنشط التركيز
بتحسن اداء الفرد بس بشرط ضمن الضوابط
اللي حكينا عنه هذه العشرين دقيق والعشر
دقائق او نصف ساعه لمده المسموح فيها ما
الذي يعني ما هو الذي يحدث في الجسم بانه
ما انت نايم بالليل واحيانا البعض ينام
بعمق او نوع النوم
يعني مرتاح
هلا اللي بصير بالقولون انه المريض او
الشخص الشيخ هو شخص لا مريض بقله النوم
بالضبط فهو الشخص بيدخل ما بدخل مرحله
النوم العميقه فالمطلوب اثناء النهار انه
ما ندخل بحاله النوم العميقه النوم السطحي
وبيسموه هذا بيعيد تنشيط الخلايا الدماغيه
بيزيد من التشابك وعمل
التواصل بين الخلايا العصبيه وهذا باثر
على نشاط الذاكره
لازم يكون قليله قصيره لانه اذا كان قليله
طويله دخل المريض بمرحله النوم العميق
وهذا بياثر سلبا بينما النوم القصير ما
دخل مرحله النوم العميق زادت نشاط الخلايا
العصبيه زاد
التشاور والتواصل
لو الواحد نام لمده ساعه ونصف ما بيكون
لسه دخل في النوم العميق ايضا ممكن يكون
دخل لذلك يفضل كلمه وصلت الماده كما كانت
ايجابيه كل ما طالت المده يكون
ساعه ونص بس هو المفروض بالقيلوله يعني 30
دقيقه ساعه ونص دكتور مستحيل يعني انا في
بعض الاحيان خصوصا في صباح العربيه مثلا
انه بنبلش بدري برجع البيت بحب اني اخذ
قيلوله مستحيل اني انام عشر دقائق او ربع
ساعه واقوم بشعري بالنشاط انا بالعكس بقوم
عندي تسارع في ضربات القلب بحس انه لازم
انام اكثر ما كنتش قادره
بكون المشكله بكون المشكله عندك نومك
بالليل قبل بيوم ما كان كافي اذا اخذه
بالضبط اذا كان نومه كافي ليلا ساعتها لا
تحتاج الى قليله طويله بينما اذا اصلا
نومك بالاساس سيء ما اخذتي كفايتك من
النوم فهل ربع ساعه ونص ساعه بالنسبه لك
ما كافيه اذا بتلاحظي الاغلب الناس اللي
بيناموا نوم عميق اثناء نهار والقانون
الطويل المديده كيف عاده بعد قليل
انتهى وقتنا الحواري كلمه واحده متى طلب
الجسم النوم ولا مؤقت معينه
لازم تحس حالك تنام تنام فتره قصيره فقط
20 دقيقه نص ساعه وفق الدكتور توفيق
الساعدي اختصاصي علم الاعصاب راح يعطيكم
نشاط شكرا جزيلا الاخبار
وعلى زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات